BY KIM JONG-UN MAY SOON BE
RELEASED.
WE HAVE THIS.
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
RIGHT HERE ON THE PROGRAM, WE
DID SOMETHING THAT YOU DON'T SEE
FROM SO- CALLED JOURNALIST.
YEAH, WE BROKE NEWS.
WE HAD A INTERVIEW WITH RUDY
GUILIANI AND REPORTS INSIGHT IN
THE LEGAL TEAM.
AND NOW RUDY GUILIANI CALLED OUT
ROBERT MUELLER'S WITCH HUNT.
>> THE PRESIDENT RIGHT WHEN HE
SAID WITCH HUNT IN>> YES, YOU
CAN'T EXPLAIN IT ANY OTHER WAY.
FIRST OF ALL THERE WAS NO
RUSSIANCLUSION AND SHOULDN'T BE
A INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE YEAR AND HALF AND TWO
YEARS IN THIS.
NO RUSSIANCLUSION.
IN FALLING ALL OVER THEMSELVES.
THEY COMMITTED NUMEROUS
VIOLATIONS.
>> Sean: GUILIANI SLAMMED THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S QUESTIONS THAT
WERE RECENTLY LEAKED TO THE NEW
YORK TIMES.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT DOES THE
PRESIDENT THINK OR FEEL, WHAT
DOES THE PRESIDENT REALLY
DESIRE, THOSE ARE QUESTIONS
INTENDED TO TRAP HIM IN SOME WAY
IN CONTRADICT WHAT IS IN FACT
A VERY, VERY SOLID EXPLANATION
OF WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Sean: THE FORMER MAYOR IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND ROBERT
MUELLER SETS A PERJURY TRAP,
THERE IS A SUBPEONA FOR
MANAFORT.
MUELLER HAS THE POWER TO
SUBPEONA SO LONG AS HE WRITES
THE NAME ON THE PAPER BEFORE HE
SERVES THE DOCUMENTS.
WHAT IS SEEMINGLY AN AGGRESSIVE
LEGAL TACTIC AND ONE THAT WE
EXPECT FROM HIM.
MORE FROM MY SIT DOWN WITH THE
MAYOR.
THE MEDIA PAID LITTLE ATTENTION
TO.
PAY ATTENTION NOW ABOUT HILLARY
CLINTON.
>> 13 CRIMES SHE COMMITTED AND
WE GOT UP TO 18.
I AM SORRY, I KNOW YOU ARE
DISAPPOINTED YOU DIDN'T WIN, BUT
YOU ARE CRIMINAL.
EQUAL JUSTICE WOULD MEAN YOU
SHOULD GO TO JAIL.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT INVESTIGATING
YOU.
>> Sean: EQUAL JUSTICE MEANS
HILLARY GOES TO JAIL.
HE TOOK ON FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY.
>> YOU HAVE AN INVESTIGATION IN
WHICH MUELLER IS SELECTED THE
DAY AFTER HE'S TURNED DOWN BY
FBI DIRECT OR BY ROSENSTEIN.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO COULD BE SELECTED FROM THE
JOB AND JAMES COMEY SEEMS TO BE
THEIR CORE OF THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
HE'S TELLING THE TRUTH AND
PRESIDENT ISN'T?
I KNOW JAMES COMEY AND I KNOW
THE PRESIDENT.
SORRY, JIM, YOU ARE A LIAR.
A DISGRACEFUL LIAR AND EVERY FBI
IN AMERICA HAS HIS HEAD DOWN
BECAUSE OF YOU.
>> Sean: THE FORMER MAYOR
SLAMMED THE FBI HANDLING OF THE
MICHAEL COHENINVESTIGATION.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> THE SETTLEMENT WHICH IS
REGULAR THING FOR LAWYERS TO DO.
ONLY POSSIBLE WOULD BE IS
WHETHER A CAMPAIGN FINANCE.
AND AS A RESULTS IN A FINE AND
NOT STORM TROOPERS BREAKING DOWN
HIS APARTMENT AND OFFICE.
>> Sean: LET'S TAKE A STEP BACK.
ALL OF THOSE CRUCIAL
DEVELOPMENTS THAT YOU JUST
WATCHED AND WE AIRED LIVE ON
THIS PROGRAM, WERE LARGELY
IGNORED BY THE ABUSIVE BIASSED
NEW'S MEDIA INSTEAD THE LAZY,
ABUSIVE BIASSED ECHO CHAMBER
"FAKE NEWS" OVER PAID MEDIA
ERUPTED 130 SECOND CLIP AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HAVING TO PAY STORMY DANIELS
WOMAN 130000?
THAT WILL BE TURN OUT TO BE
PERFECTLY ALMOST.
THAT MONEY WAS NOT CAMPAIGN
MONEY.
I AM GIVING YOU A FACT THAT YOU
DON'T KNOW.
IT IS NOT CAMPAIGN MONEY.
NO CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
>> Sean: SO THEY FUNNELED --
FUNDED BY THE LAW FARM.
>> Sean: IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
FACT AND PURPOSE OF THE PAYMENT
INITIALLY OR A LONG TIME UNTIL
AFTER THE TRANSACTION TOOK PLACE
AND MICHAEL COHEN, TOOK THE
ACTION TO BENEFIT THE COMPANY HE
SERVEMENT FOLLOW THE BOUNCING
BALL SO YOU CAN KEEP UP.
WALL STREET JOURNAL REPORTED
ABOUT THE COHEN, PAYMENT TO
STORMY DANIELS THAT HAPPENED
BEFORE THE ELECTION AND IN
FEBRUARY IN AN INTERVIEW WITH
THE NEW YORK TIMES, MICHAEL
COHENDENIED THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
REIMBURSED HIM.
HE LEFT OPEN THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF THEN
PRESIDENT-ELECT AT THE TIME
MIGHT HAVE REIMBURSED HIM WITH
PERSONAL FUNDS.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THIS ON
BOARD OF A FORCE ONE.
DID YOU KNOW ABOUT THE PAYMENT?
>> YOU HAVE TO REQUEST MICHAEL
COHEN, MY ATTORNEY.
YOU WILL HAVE TO ASK MICHAEL.
>> NOW THE PRESIDENT OBVIOUSLY
KNEW ABOUT THE STORY AT THIS
TIME.
IT WAS SO WIDELY REPORTED SINCE
JANUARY AND WHAT HE SAID, HE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE PAYMENT
PRIOR TO THE STORY BEING
COVERED.
THIS DID NOT STOP THE HYSTERIA
OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WITH
A FEVER PITCH LIKE THE RUSSIA,
STORY.
>> I DID NOT WATCH ALL OF YOUR
SHOW.
RUDY GUILIANI WENT ON FOX NEWS
AND HE STAYED ON LONGER THAN HE
IS HAVE, THAT'S WHEN HE GOT TO
THE STORMY DANIELS.
WHICH IS BLOCKBUSTER.
>> AND HE COULD BE OUT THERE
DEFENDING THE PRESIDENT AND TAKE
A HARDER LINE WHEN IT CAME TO
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
BUT HE CREATED ANOTHER MYTH.
>> THERE IS AN ASSUMPTION THAT
RUDDY GUILIANI HAD A STRATEGY
AND I AM UNCONVINCED THAT THAT
IS THE CASE.
>> HAD RUDY GUILIANI BEEN
COUNSEL FOR IBM AND UNDERCUT IBM
LIKE HE DID FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES HE WOULD BE
FIRED NEXT MORNING.
THE HERO OF 9/11 IS FORGOTTEN
AND SEVERELY DAMAGED HIS LEGACY.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
GUILIANI'S LEGAL STRATEGY.
>> HE MET PHORICALLY MURDERED
THE PRESIDENT AND COMMITTED
SUICIDE WITH RESPECT TO HIS OWN
REPUTATION.
>> Sean: 24 HOUR COVERAGE WAS
OBSESSIVE AND IT WAS ALMOST
FUNNY EXCEPT THAT IT IS TOO
SERIOUS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> STUNNING REVELATION FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY RUDY
GUILIANI.
LAST NIGHT TESTIFYING FOX NEWS
THAT TRUMP REIMBURSEMENT HIS
FIXER.
>> IT WAS A STUNNING ADMISSION
THAT GUILIANI SAID APPROVED BY
HIS BOSS THE PRESIDENT AND
OFFERING A CONTRADICTORY ACCOUNT
ABOUT THE PAYMENT TO STORMY
DANIELS.
>> AFTER SAYING HE DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THE HUSH PAYMENT.
AND NOW HE REIMBURSED HIS
LAWYER.
>> STARTLING ADMISSION BY RUDY
GUILIANI HAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
FACING NEW QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER HE KNEW ABOUT THE
ATTEMPT TO SILENCE STORMY
DANIELS.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA CAN'T STOP
PLAYING THE SHOW AND HANNITY AND
THEY FEATURE ME MORE THAN THEIR
OWN HOSTS.
I AM BEGINNING TO THINK I NEED
TO COLLECT A PAYCHECK FROM ABC,
CBS, AND NBC, AND MSNBC.
AND I AM PROVIDING THE REAL NEWS
THAT THEY RARELY MAKE ON THEIR
OWN.
TURN TO EVEN MORE "FAKE NEWS".
THIS IS SERIOUS.
NBC BROKE A SERIOUS STORY ABOUT
MICHAEL COHEN.
ACCORDING TO THE ORIGINAL
REPORT.
COHEN, HAD BEEN WIRETAPPED WEEKS
BEFORE HE WAS RAIDED BY THE FBI.
AND THERE WAS MORE DEVELOPMENTS
BY NBC NEWS.
>> THE WIRETAP OCCURRED BEFORE
THE PUBLIC SEARCH WARRANT.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT, WE
LEARNED THAT ONE PHONE CALL
CONVERSATION BETWEEN MICHAEL
COHENAND THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
INTERCEPTED AND WE KNOW THAT
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR CONDUCTED
A SURVEILLANCE OF HIS E-MAILS
LEADING UP TO A SEARCH WARRANT.
THIS IS MORE THAN KNOCKING ON
THE DOOR AND ASKING FOR
DOCUMENTLESS.
>> Sean: AND ONCE AGAIN WE
LEARNED THAT THIS REPORT WAS
"FAKE NEWS" AND NBC WAS FORCED
TO REPORT.
THREE SENIOR OFFICIALS DISPUTE
THE WIRETAPPING AND THE
MONITORING OF COHEN'S CALL WAS